[Music]
[Applause]
oh he's there he's back he's Chris
Mannix our good buddy the Sports
Illustrated senior writer he has been a
busy man here I you want to start with
MVP
the Sacramento Kings the dangerous
Lakers
Durant's back whichever you pick
whichever way you want to go Dan you can
start with MVP since I was just reading
before we came on Tim Bond temps my
friend over at ESPN had his latest straw
poll uh which shows the race between
Nicole jokic and John Beaton to a lesser
extent Giannis decompo uh tightening
pretty uh pretty good so we can start
there
it feels like it's contentious not
between embiid and the Joker but the
writers and fan base can you I I don't
remember this being this way
I don't think it's contentious among the
writers it's contentious certainly among
the fans it's contentious certainly on
social media
um you know radio TV personalities some
of them have you know made it seem like
if you vote for player X that means you
hate player Y which none of the writers
actually believe uh I'm an MVP voter and
look I've I've gone back and forth on
this vote but not because I you know
feel differently or I hate Nicola jokic
more than I did back in February when I
voted the first time but circumstances
change you know since the last you know
ESPN straw poll you've seen the Bucks go
on a 15-game winning streak you've seen
the Sixers eight out of ten and Joel
embiid play out of his mind so things
just change that's why the voting habits
change if you go back to December Dan
Jason Tatum was the leader in the m MVP
Clubhouse so you know things just tend
to evolve over season how do you think
this plays out
it's going to come down to potentially
which team gets hot in the final couple
of weeks of the season
potentially which player takes off I
mean I was one of the few people that
cast my unofficial vote this week for
Giannis
um Giannis I think is the most complete
two-way player that's that's left uh
among those top three the bucks right
now have the best record in basketball
and the Bucks have done it with Chris
Middleton playing like 30 games this
season you know every other player that
we're talking about in the MVP race has
a All-Star or All-Star caliber co-star
or co-stars
um yes Drew holiday is right there in
that mix but Chris Middleton is the
number two in Milwaukee and his absence
while James Harden has been playing
while Jamal Murray has been playing
Michael Porter Jr even playing in uh in
Denver you know that's a variable to me
so Giannis kind of taking this team and
elevating them to the best record in the
NBA right now uh that gave him a slight
Edge on my most recent talking to Chris
Mannix from Sports Illustrated their
senior writer how about my Kings hello
uh how big is this story
huge it's huge
um
one of the most wildly entertaining
teams I've seen in a while probably the
most entertaining since you know Mike
d'antoni's teams from back in the day
because they are wait more entertaining
than me than Golden State yeah
yeah because Golden State would play
defense and Sacramento which makes them
even more entertaining like it just
it's just fun watching this team get the
ball out of their own basket run up the
floor and try to score that's why it's
kind of shades of the Dan Tony Sons I
mean even the Dan Tony Sons during their
best years where you could find them 15
20 in defense Sacramento in most
categories is bottom five and you watch
them and and I've watched a lot of Kings
games this year because again they are
fun to watch but you watch them and it's
not like the effort's not there
defensively it's not like the schemes
aren't there defensively because Mike
Brown is an excellent defensive coach
they're just fundamentally bad like top
to bottom they are bad defensively from
sabonis to Fox Kevin herder great
offensive players Dynamic at some
positions but straight bad defensively
that's why you know most of these scores
are like 130 120 140 132. it just makes
them so much fun to fun to watch but
ending this drought is impressive but
it's entertaining but is it can you win
with this in the playoffs
no no you absolutely cannot win with
this in the playoffs okay you know I the
match-ups are going to be interesting
because right now you look at the bottom
of the Western Conference playoff
standings and you see in no particular
order the Clippers the Lakers the
Timberwolves it's very easy to Envision
a scenario not just where the Kings get
knocked out in the first round but any
of the top three teams right now in the
Western Conference getting knocked out
in the first round but specific to the
Kings
you've got to be like
I don't know better than a bottom third
defensive team to to succeed in the
playoffs when you can't run as much when
possessions become a lot more valuable
and I think the king's gonna have some
fun moments in the postseason but I
don't see them getting very far with
that defense the most dangerous team in
the west is who
Lakers
most dangerous team in the west and Dan
I will tell you right now the Lakers are
going to win the Western Conference wow
that is my prediction to you today okay
they will win the Western Conference
um it's not it's not knee-jerk to what
we saw last night against Chicago it's
more of a combination of everything I've
seen over the last few weeks with
Anthony Davis again playing like Anthony
Davis Austin Reeves taking off in the
second half of the season the trades
that they made these guys that fit
D'Angelo Russell he fits rui hashimura
good role player Jared Vanderbilt you
get some kind of Dennis Rodman Vibes off
Jared Vanderbilt when he's in the game
and LeBron he came back from this foot
injury a little bit earlier than people
thought he would which gives him more of
a Runway to get back into a rhythm
before the start of the playoffs I mean
since the All-Star breakdown they have a
top four defense in the league and
I just see too many signs that suggest
when they get to the playoffs they're
going to be dangerous there because who
who do you fear like who are you picking
in the first round against the Lakers
right now they're in number eight do
they play Denver do you pick the Nuggets
over the Lakers I'm sorry I wouldn't
Memphis they're a mess right now uh
Sacramento we talked about them I think
the Lakers the biggest threat to the
Lakers in my opinion are the teams they
could play in the second and third round
at the bottom half of the bracket if the
Warriors get Andrew Wiggins back and
they start playing like the Warriors the
Clippers get Paul George back those are
the teams uh the Suns we can get into
them I mean if they get their chemistry
right uh those are the teams that would
make me more anxious if I was the Lakers
than Den from Memphis or Sacramento yeah
I thought you would say Phoenix would be
the most dangerous team with Durant
coming back
how come they're not the most dangerous
team
they're right up there but I still need
to see more from this version of Phoenix
I don't put much stock in what Durant
did last night first game back and I can
only imagine with an ankle injury that
was so bizarre there's going to be some
comfort issues coming back into into the
fall but you know Chris Paul continues
to have an inconsistent shooting year I
want to see who's that kind of fourth
and fifth guy off of or fifth guy really
off of the top four that they have in in
Phoenix how does that bench shape out
it's kind of a thin bench right now and
look they've got a lot of guys Dan that
have been dealing with you know soft
tissue injuries muscle injuries
different things like that over the
course uh of the Season DeAndre ayton
just missed four games with a hip injury
you know that's a dangerous team because
of their star power
but in the playoffs I mean
it feels like they're one moment away
from one of those guys going down which
would completely derail their plans
help me understand the Ben Simmons
situation
what happens next
you've just got to continue the
rehabilitation Pro process if you're
Brooklyn there's
there's no other alternative at this
point there's no market for Ben Simmons
uh nobody in the NBA really knows if
you're making like the Ben Simmons pie
chart how much of it is mental how much
of it is physical how much of it is the
situation there's just there's a lot of
questions around him to the point where
nobody is going to touch him certainly
not with the numbers that are left on
that contract I mean the Nets there's no
pressure on Brooklyn right now because
they're not going to win anything for
the foreseeable future so I believe
their mindset this off season with a
full off season with Simmons being
relatively healthy is to just try to
find unique ways to get him back on
track because they really don't have any
other choice like there's there's no
other destination for Ben Simmons
there's no place they can trade him
they're certainly not going to cut him
and eat all that money they've got to
figure out this summer a way to fix Ben
Simmons so that he is something close to
the player we've once seen in years past
yeah and you know it's like markelle
fultz worked to come back yeah and and
really it's been a a really good story
but he disappeared in Orlando it's like
Ben Simmons needs to disappear someplace
so we don't focus on his game every
single night or he's not playing for a
contender where he's hurting that team
and then maybe he gets some confidence
back but man you can't go from defensive
player of the year to averaging 17 and
eight and then you're not even playing
anymore like
I don't know
mind-boggling look the people the people
around Ben Simmons will tell you that
everything is kind of an offshoot of the
initial injury whether it's the knee
connects to the hip connects to the back
all those things have been giving Ben
Simmons problem but I couldn't agree
with you more of that Ben Simmons needs
to get back in anonymity which is
exactly what fultz did and there were
some similarities there because false's
injuries did appear to be both physical
and mental and he went to Orlando where
there was no pressure and you know he's
had some injuries down there but as a
player he has been able to revive his
career look maybe Brooklyn is
that destination I mean the Nets are in
New York but you know even when they're
great nobody really cares there's still
a Nick's town so that that could be his
opportunity to to rebuild himself next
year but he can't play for a contender
right now not with that type of pressure
would you rather be a Knicks fan or a
Kings fan right now
oh
I'd probably rather be a Kings fan not
just for this year but for the
foreseeable future because
I can project out four or five years of
the king's rising in in the playoff
standings in the playoff field becoming
a contender if they can add a couple of
defensive players
um they could be at another level the
Knicks
I can they just reek a first round exit
they just do like they they're better
than what they were in years past
because Jalen Brunson is there and Jalen
brunson's a game changer I think Jalen
Brunson deserves
you know credit for elevating Julius
Randle this year because you know you
Julius randle's playing more like the
guy we saw two years ago than the one we
saw last year and that has a lot to do
with uh with Jalen Brunson but
I still don't trust that team in the
playoffs I've watched too many Knicks
games Dan where where Randall just grabs
the ball with under five minutes left
and you know goes one on five sometimes
and defense have kind of figured him out
you saw in the playoffs a couple of
years ago against Atlanta you know a
couple of games they they you know to
break it down or boil it down they see
him kind of look one way they send a
double team from another and force him
to either turn the ball over or take a
bad shot
that's just not a team I can trust right
now it's a great matchup on Friday by
the way with a team they're likely to
face in the first round that's Cleveland
I think Cleveland's a more complete team
than uh than the Knicks are they're
overall better defensively and I think
Donovan Mitchell will be the best player
on the floor in that series it won't be
great to see Donovan Mitchell go to
Madison Square Garden and break the
hearts of all Knicks fans I just I think
the Knicks are a team that's built for
pretty good success in the regular
season but when you get to the playoffs
and you're going to be forced to rely on
Julius Randle and forced to ask for
efficiency from RJ Barrett and forced to
have Jalen Brunson uh step up into a
bigger role I'm just not buying them I
think the Kings have a higher ceiling
I'll leave you with this I'm big on body
language and I'm watching the Mavs last
night
Luca does not look good man
how's this end
I I don't know he look he's in year one
of a long-term contract but the
Mavericks made this Kyrie deal because
they're worried about
Luca asking out in the foreseeable
future and you know whenever I check in
with people in Dallas it's made clear to
me in no uncertain terms that they don't
blame Kyrie for what's going on down
here
um Tyree by all accounts has been a
great locker room guy a pretty good
leader
saying it's a cluster bleep last night
was probably not a page out of Dale
Carnegie but it he was a uh he has been
a pretty good soldier down in Dallas the
problem they have Dan is their roster is
deeply flawed you watch you know Luca
and Kyrie are not good defensive players
but when there's nobody behind them to
clean up their mistakes they become
exponentially worse because you can't
rely on javel McGee and Dwight Powell
and Maxi klieber to be defensive
Stoppers so if you are if you have two
turnstiles at the top of the perimeter
you're not gonna have much success
getting stops uh in the paint it reminds
me a lot of what the Jazz look like in
recent years of Rudy gobert was out of
the lineup where they could score a
bunch of points but they couldn't stop
anybody and I don't know how it gets
better next season like let's say let's
spin it forward and let's say you bring
Kyrie back on a long-term deal which is
a massive risk in and of itself like you
don't have flexibility to go out and get
the wing stopper that you had in Dorian
Finney Smith you have no flexibility to
get the perimeter or the interior big
you have no flexibility to flesh out
that roster you're just gonna have to
hope that those two guys catch lightning
in a bottle and can outscore you on most
nights and that's not a that's not a
recipe for Success it's really not so
they were better I think it's going to
end poorly they were better before they
made the trade
they were a better team it was a paddock
move yes it was a panic move because
they they failed last year with Jalen
Brunson we don't need to go back down
that path that was a catastrophic
mistake not re-signing him the first or
second time that they had the
opportunity and now they go out and you
know with the only team really in the
NBA willing to roll the dice on Kyrene
look at the off season Dan like who's
out there that would take a chance on
Kyrie besides Dallas this summer like
the Lakers I mean
if they do that if they go out there and
gut their roster to get Kyrie Irving
that would be one of the most
dysfunctional moves I've seen in a while
the Suns have no interest Kevin Durant
doesn't look like he wants to be
anywhere near Kyrie anymore like some of
the Caps based teams like Detroit San
Antonio are they making a run at Kyrie
Irving like it it's Dallas or Bust It
Feels Like right now for Kyrie good to
talk to you as always thanks again Chris
you got it Dan that's Chris Mannix
senior writer for sports illustrator
we'll take a break our play of the day
is up next